the Joe Rogan experience yeah I have a
theory I don't give myself any credit
when I have these talks when things are
going well like it's good it helped you
know like but if I can be in a tense
moment and get out of it right where I
would have then I give it then I'll be
proud of myself yeah that's the thing
about all that motivational speaking
stuff right like yeah it's like the guy
who's doing all the motivational
speaking if he's pulling up in a Rolls
Royce and he lives in a big mansion so
yeah you're enthusiastic look
everything's going great how are you
if someone takes all this stuff away
then and it becomes right I can use can
you be stoic can you be at peace when
you're broke and you're by yourself and
some one bedroom apartment somewhere can
you can you do it all over again
that's a suburb you know could you
imagine someone told you Dane Cook was
the first one ever heard talk about this
so give him credit for that he said I
would not never want to try to do
stand-up again I don't think I could do
it like that it was so hard to do that I
would never want to start and do it
again did you ever think like what it
would be like you got to start again
like right now you don't you have zero
jokes you've never done stand-up but
somehow or another you have this vague
memory of the grind that it takes to
become an actual professional I think I
do in a heart I think definitely
definitely definitely definitely but
that's because you already know right
you already know you could do it it
would be a totally different thing
question now that I think about a [ __ ]
Dane Cook just can't do Dane
don't get upset but I'm saying if you if
you think about it like that doesn't
even make any sense because of course
you would know that you could make it so
it'd be way easier even if you just
start it all can't believe in 21 again
doing stand-up this is ridiculous
are you are you 21 again or you just are
you are you'd have to start from scratch
I just do it to get younger but then
once you made the decision you would in
unless you live in some bizarro world
we're allowed to live two lives you
would never even have memory right you'd
run 21 that's what I thought you would
you all I'd have to do is just say yes
yes 21 again it's a stupid [ __ ]
question
it's
maybe have a little loss maybe he'd be
like now I said this and that I don't
think he thought it through you said
something a minute ago and I that's what
I should write [ __ ] down was it about
the food thing no no no what were you
just talking about before the we're
talking about discipline like hard asses
and then then we got to like how
difficult it would be to start over do
it I think anything like if you said
that to a brain surgeon you want to
start from scratch start from you know
right right after you graduated high
school you want to take it from day one
freshman year college no [ __ ] that
did you ever think of like I know two
things I would have done like before
when did you start stand-up eight excuse
me I was 21 did you is there a job you
when you were in high school did you
think you thought you knew what you
wanted to do maybe for a living not
really my number one option was teaching
Taekwondo which already was doing that's
what I was doing
Oh see you were already yeah but I
didn't I didn't want to fight anymore
and I didn't think that I didn't think
that did be like a real future in me
teaching I didn't really like teaching
everybody I only like teaching people
that were super enthusiastic because I
was I was young at the time like when I
was first started teaching on my own I
was 19 I was teaching at Boston
University I had my own school for you
were 21 of 19
Wow yeah and in Boston yeah in Boston
yeah I taught I taught a pass/fail a
class like they can get credit for it
and I would say all you have to do is
just show up and you get an A just try
just trying to get an AIDS has nothing
to do your physical performance because
the idea that everybody's starting on
the same page is ridiculous
some of these people have like serious
athletic backgrounds some of these
people never worked out a day in their
life and they thought it'd be fun to try
something new so the idea of like
grading them against each other I said
I'll give you guys all an A I know you
and and you I'm their age are you
allowed to do that
that's the teacher like they they really
the worst thing you do is fire me and I
didn't care because it only paid like
200 bucks a month or something was right
it wasn't expensive wasn't a valuable
thing
it was a prestigious things like I'm
teaching at a university and I'm 19 did
most people get the a everybody got an a
no I mean I offered all the times I
taught I talked for a couple years one
or two people just didn't show up you
know there you're always gonna have that
yeah why don't you people just say [ __ ]
they [ __ ] off but I just made it fun you
know I was their age and so we just we
did a lot of cool [ __ ] and kick pads and
I taught them how to turn their hip and
stuff and how you know how to get power
and things you could see them it's a
there's something very enthusiastic
about someone regardless of what their
physical ability is getting a little bit
better and seeing it you know even if
they start from nothing and then you see
just yes yes you're getting it you're
getting it and then see them beam like
this that that to me was what I was into
what I wasn't into is people that needed
to be motivated they they just didn't
they couldn't they would they just
half-ass things they weren't
enthusiastic they were distracted maybe
they were talking too much like you
could do all that stuff another time but
if you want to get good at this there's
only one way you have to be really
interested in getting good at it you got
to be really focused on all the things
you're doing right or wrong
whenever I see a comedian like you go
back a year to a club you saw a comedian
he's a newer comedian if he has been
going up at least twice a week and it's
52 weeks later right it's fun to see
that type of improve oh yeah and you're
like wow like yeah if maybe I've gone up
what 300 times since you've been here
yeah but you can tell if they haven't
[Applause]